it's hard it's hard I know you know what
to do it's hard it's like close your
eyes for four years nothing good is
gonna happen for four years so I just
got out of a meeting how's it going yeah
really well I didn't even know that
Taylor was coming in today and it took
me a second you probably can see it I'm
like holy [ __ ]
so the super exciting for me even what
you're about to watch is a follow-up
meeting - no question good good to go
the most viral moment of the askgaryvee
show here's the full askgaryvee moment
with the follow-up interview that I just
did or the catch-up that I just did I
genuinely believe in my heart and soul
that for everybody 22 that 98% of people
that are 22 to 30 are about to get a
piece of content that is fundamentally
gonna change their life I'm not sure
about a year ago I actually called in
why got called into the askgaryvee show
so I talked to you about a year ago I'm
from Buffalo
I remember hello
hey Taylor its Gary being on the
askgaryvee show no way yes way okay
where are you from I'm from Buffalo New
York I love are you Bills fan ah
unfortunately yes all right I know you
said I'm fortunate it's very good I know
well listen neither are the Jets don't
worry so what's going on not much I
basically would dying to ask you a
question
currently graduated college last May and
I'm trying to build my own business plan
hustle all that kind of stuff and my
question for you is and I'm probably
sure that a lot of people ask this
they're wondering thing okay how do you
get over the stump of you're graduating
and you feel this pressure because
you're trying to build something but
you're still so young but you want to do
this fast and grow it big and I'm just
gonna write and I can't get out of it
but I have a hustle in the drive that I
know I'll be able to build something but
I'm just in this space they're not
allowing me to so let me
help you the space you're in is probably
the macro micro issue so it's macro
patience micro speed right so what do I
in by that you need to be patient as
[ __ ] Taylor you're you're 22 23 years
old like what do you think is gonna
happen overnight
yeah I know so you need to be fast 7
a.m. to 2:00 in the morning everyday but
in the big picture you need to realize
nothing good is gonna happen for the
next 6 years okay and do you think that
I should just try every good idea that I
think I have and just go for it all out
or do you think I should stick with one
thing at a time I think the fact that
you even asked that question that you
should taste flirting with a lot of
different things because you'll be
crippled by the what if if you don't
even though that's not the perfect
formula to build the biggest short-term
wealth because you should go dip triple
down on one thing instead of being half
pregnant online okay Taylor let me tell
you something you like let me ask you
the pressure chlorine like are you
trying to prove to yourself to your
siblings to your parents to the world
like who are you trying to prove that
you're successful to or that this was
the right call or you're gonna make it
like that's what you have to figure out
mmm what do you like what are you
impatient for like what's what's the
problem you want to buy a [ __ ] Rolex
like what's the what what's the rush I
feel like I've known that I'm going to
do something big reppin an
entrepreneurial house me too and so it's
in my blood it's in my bone and good and
I feel like I watched all these other
Millennials hitting these huge I guess
milestones in their life miles and then
I sit here let's break it down how old
are you I'm 22 all about 323 okay what
miles please give me a millennial and
the milestone they achieved that makes
you feel like you're just sitting in
[ __ ] Buffalo well I'm sitting in
Buffalo which is one thing I'm not happy
about that's right because it's on the
Buffalo Bills piece of [ __ ]
but why but but yeah before you go there
forget about sitting in Buffalo
who's the millennial and what's the
milestone that's making you feel like
you're sitting there go the truth go
well honestly there's people on social
media which definitely is not always
true but I watch ok I guess the only
thing on the spot I can think of is a
Kardashian or a Jenner who is just lamb
but can we talk about this yeah I feel
like sure like you're telling me that
Kylie Jenner's [ __ ] trillion
followers on Instagram makes you feel
like you're just sitting there no I feel
like the fact that she's already got a
business started that's super successful
did you fact that her fan did you factor
in the fact that her sisters and mom
architected something for ten years
while she was a teenager that she was
able to walk directly into that gave her
a springboard and that she had the
financial capabilities of deploying
ungodly amounts of you know plastic
surgery and the and all the other
variable things that she's been able to
do to create that culture and that
financial benefit yeah did you factor in
that her mom is a ninja architect of
business and created that framework yeah
and I feel like not many people give
them the credit for that I totally think
that I agree with this Empire
I agree but what the [ __ ] does that have
to do with you it has nothing to do with
me I know
[ __ ] remember how I don't know if you
saw this where I said stop looking at
your friends [ __ ] or whatever [ __ ] I put
on Instagram yeah I don't know if you
saw it or not but it doesn't matter what
the like you looking at the Kardashians
is the most ludicrous horseshit I've
ever heard in my life
well that's the first thing that could
pop into my heart right give me that
listen we're here we're here give me
another one
there's a guy in London I can't I just
say if I must I need to stop you right
now okay let me give you some I was
gonna say father I guess my father was
Ford and now I'll give you some
massively older brother uncle advice you
ready okay yeah
every second you spend thinking about
what somebody else has is taking away
from time that you could create
something for yourself yeah you're
losing you're losing because you're
laying in your bed looking at somebody's
[ __ ] glamorous photoshopped picture
of them doing something cool and you're
envious and you're jealous and you're
impatient and it's crippling you're
upside yeah cuz that's where I want to
be and I know I'm not there yet you
haven't done [ __ ] I know so don't do
[ __ ] that actually gets you there so
that you earn it instead of like you
dwelling that you're not there and
hoping something's gonna happen I don't
know what's going through your mind yeah
well I guess I'm hustling on the sides I
don't think I'm doing enough I guess you
definitely aren't doing enough if you
have enough time to [ __ ] consume the
content of a Kardashian and some boy in
London okay listen to me Taylor listen
you've got to deploy patience and you've
got to love the process I'm addicted to
the process of the battle scars the
setbacks the lack of you know Taylor I
gave up my entire 20s all of them
imagine not doing anything fun or going
anywhere for the next eight years
including Saturday and Sunday that's
what I did from 22 to 30 every day I
spent 15 hours a day in a liquor store
thought about a liquor store built a
liquor store sold wine like spent every
day like this last weekend don't lie to
me Taylor what didn't you do this last
weekend why didn't you do [ __ ] front
Saturday and Sunday tell me the truth
don't [ __ ] me yeah no [ __ ] I'm
helping my mom right now on visual media
and branding for her company Muldoon so
I had a marketing meeting with one of
the people of doing that love you and
then I also how much time did you have
how much time to be up for yourself on
Saturday and Sunday that was not working
every minute tell me the truth a lot a
lot I know so that's the punchline right
now imagine that yeah when I tell you
this you spent more downtime on not your
career this weekend than I did in my
entire 20s combined oh [ __ ] okay
that puts things into perspective I
think so
Arthur I think so - yeah I need to get
to it tell her you need to do me a huge
favor if you really want to win and you
want to come to New York in eight years
and shake my hand here's what you need
to do you need to stop giving a [ __ ]
about what anybody else has and realized
that if you put your head down and just
work for the next ten years no glamour
no new [ __ ] car suitcase jewelry trip
event no Coachella no [ __ ] new
[ __ ] sneakers like [ __ ] work you
will have it and every time you care
about one of the things I just mentioned
it will slow down your process of having
it okay so in less than eight years when
I'm a millionaire by twenty-five I'll
come shake your hand I promise you that
statement itself made me 100 percent
guarantee that you won't yes that's how
this works being a millionaire 25 when
you're 22 and you're a dick [ __ ] and
haven't even started it's inconceivable
unless you [ __ ] hit the lotto
what's the romance what's the romance of
I want to make you know how everybody
says Gary Vee wouldn't you to buy the
Jets in two years and then I replied 20
years I'm a romantic about the journey
in the process which is why I'm actually
gonna pull it off you're trying to be a
millionaire by 25 how Taylor it's just a
god I've always had one right now with
what I'm doing I guess it's not that's
right it's an arbitrary [ __ ] thing
that means nothing yeah wouldn't you
want guarantee millionaire ship by 36
then by doing long-term marathon running
versus doing a bunch of [ __ ]
Sprint's that guarantees never having it
and I promise you a funny thing happens
to your self-esteem when you're 31 and
not a millionaire because you've been
chasing fast [ __ ] cash and you're now
6 years removed from not hitting your
goal your self-esteem starts [ __ ]
with your head mm-hmm yeah listen
carefully I want it I want to buy the
New York Jets but when I clarify it to
everybody I want the process of trying
to buy the New York Jets more than
buying the New York
let's understand yeah
because ultimately that's the end goal
but there's a process behind that you
have to understand I don't give a [ __ ]
about the end goal I care about the
process the enjoyment of doing it you're
not enjoying yourself trying to get to a
million bucks over the next three years
now really you're right oh I know I'm
right I'm just sticking on this right
now because I feel like we've gone into
this deep enough that I might as well
hold on for a couple more minutes to see
if I could actually pull you through
instead of you just being on this hi of
practicality for 36 hours and then going
back to Instagram [ __ ] in 48 hours I
mean if you activate that [ __ ] no you
need to learn the discipline to be able
to put it in the proper bucket yeah I
just feel like I hold myself at this
pedestal me it's crippling myself
because I'm not actually doing the
things to get there
of course so you're playing a fake
narrative instead of putting in the
actual work that's needed to actually
pull it off wishing instead of executing
and then and then what's happening is
you're living a fake world to yourself
but you know it which then changes your
behavior in the way that you interact
with others okay
I know like for all my bravado now I was
real quiet in my 20s people made fun of
me like you work in your dad's liquor
store I'm in Wall Street making a
hundred thousand I got a BMW I'm like
that's nice Pat yeah do you understand
the level of disrespect I have for Pat
d-lab do you understand the level of
disrespect I have for all those 20 30 40
50 year olds flashing [ __ ] on [ __ ]
Instagram with short term news I can't
wait for the [ __ ] world to melt I
can't wait for all these [ __ ] people
to get [ __ ] hosed out when the
economy gets [ __ ] yes because their
short term affording these things that
are flashy but in the long term it's not
sustainable for what they're doing right
now yeah but meanwhile you're admiring
the [ __ ] out of them I know it's a
problem make [ __ ] hit it's really bad
Taylor you need to start [ __ ] love in
the process and the work and the grind
you need to start respecting people that
are like sleeping within like with four
roommates and buying their t-shirts at
Wall
yeah you know what I feel like I need
that wake up but I feel like I need to
hit rock bottom and just have that wake
up I'm too comfortable right now and
it's annoying that [ __ ] out of me I
don't I don't think so I think you are
saying you need to hit rock bottom
because it buys you more time to
[ __ ] like you are right now hmm I
never thought of that you know what I
mean
like you know it's not working you're
just saying by the way let me go
complete left-field on you
you're a 22 year old girl woman like
it's okay to enjoy a little bit now -
you've heard me say regrets if you I
don't know how deep you know my content
but once in a blue moon when people ask
me the advice for 25 year old Gary the
answer is go have fun
[ __ ] it would've been okay to go to
Vegas Acapulco or like like do some dumb
[ __ ] like do you know what I mean like
so so yeah so I think I've had my fun in
college though and now I feel like it's
time to work well you're you know no
that's the [ __ ] PR version Taylor
the reality Taylor is still [ __ ] in
that zone hmm yeah don't beat yourself
up don't hold yourself accountable to
arbitrary [ __ ] fantasies just put in
work and enjoy that enjoy eating [ __ ]
and dirt and bleeding and the grind and
don't give a [ __ ] about what anybody
else thinks why you haven't done it why
are you doing that have four jobs
[ __ ] Wendy's Walmart your side hustle
work
train learn don't think you're a digital
expert just cuz you're 22 and you have
an Instagram account show me how much
[ __ ] [ __ ] you've sold with your
digital social media skills okay do you
understand no I do yeah you're just
you're just you're just completely in
the wrong game and I'm holding you on to
this because you and 99% of the people
that are watching or playing the same
game I know it's just what I wanted to
ask the question but you know I can't
but you're obviously not the only one no
you're the majority and and the massive
majority the question is you just need
to be stuck you just need to understand
the following you can trick losers
you're not tricking me good because I
want honest answers
don't need my honest answer you know
you're not tricking yourself either none
of us are tricking ourselves I just want
to remind you that you might be able to
trick your uncle Hal and you might be
able to trick your girlfriend that was
in your [ __ ] college with you but
you're not tricking a winner when you're
bullshitting got it got it so even if
your posturing and pandering and PR and
yourself no winner thinks you're winning
yeah because I'm not I know work that's
the answer to all these questions now I
learn things do stuff trying to sell
[ __ ] learn how to make money work all
right I will this is good awesome thank
you so much can you do me a huge favor
yeah can you email me in 30 days and
don't [ __ ] me what's your Twitter
handle for Instagram once again hang up
that's why Instagram is at the fabulous
journey at the fabulous journey yeah me
and my whole team in the entire
vaynernation is watching oh [ __ ]
okay I'm gonna sighs I'm gonna smoke you
out of your [ __ ] okay
everybody's watching okay
I got it do you understand yeah I like
your D dress thank you I got ourselves
not like that answer that's the best
thing you said all listen slow and
steady wins the race
you're only competing with yourself okay
got it got it nobody else to find you
not me not everybody watching that your
mom not the [ __ ] Kardashians
you got it you can grind and be patient
for 10 years every day and still be nine
years younger than me and I would trade
places with you that's how amazing
having time on your side is yeah times
everything so use it oh well good see ya
thank you you're welcome
we're excited to be here you actually
kind of changed a lot for me oh [ __ ] um
it's a little crazy okay tell me I mean
it was such a viral moment that and it
was kind of like a light switch for me
um I used to be you know really gung-ho
super energetic always working correctly
my family business all the kind of stuff
and then I don't have enough of
graduation it kind of just like it's
what happens to a lot of people yeah
it's the trick it's why I'm so
passionate about doing what I'm doing
right now for all of you characters cuz
I genuinely believe 22 to 28 22 to 30 is
tricky times yeah I think the biggest
thing that's happened in the last year
since having the conversation with Gary
is complete mental shifting to like
self-awareness and I mean he says
patience but really like be patient
um has been the biggest thing for me and
what's really tough for me is that most
of it is other people's voices
manifested into your head it sounds like
your voice but it's not did it wake you
up from the call itself or all the
collateral that happened after because
because there was a lot that happened
there yeah
like the amount of like smiling faces
right now on the other side of however
d-roc is gonna edit this it's like you
know there's a lot of I mean you were
probably one of the most known
characters you know I remember course um
so that was that was the point
I got suffocated yep
as the aftermath was like well is that
was the point to create accountability
after the fact that's why I went there
and I've slowly been trying to make
something of it and I have a real clear
vision of what I want it to be but when
it comes like process and steps and like
okay what's the next step like what are
those that's not clear yet no I make
sense I mean look and tell you until
you're in that mode to be an operator
like running a business sounds great in
theory it's no different it's no
different anything else like in theory
it sounds great to be a chef or or you
know like if there's just such a missed
note this is back to like my big thing
with 22 to 30
everyone's like I'm gonna start a
business cool but nobody says I'm gonna
be an NBA player cold at 22 but it's the
same thing like being successful this is
hard okay so keep going really cool cuz
what I started last March
that's good which is really cool just to
watch you know the progression and what
I have now are ideas and I'm starting to
try to create like a campaign type of it
you know I want to create some sort of
video that I could start to market
Facebook Ads is not what I know so I
know people so that's kind of where I'm
going with that what do you say
yeah good the question that I had though
I had a couple but most specifically is
how do you find that person to help you
grow the business because I'm very much
I know why I want to do it
I want what are you selling so it's
started as an apparel company but I
actually want it to be a community first
so I want to build a community that
totally encompasses people who are like
me people who want to be entrepreneurs
or where they want to be creatives
where is the community gonna live
physically where is it gonna live are
you is the community gonna live in the
comment sections of your content is it
gonna live on an email is going to live
in a closed Facebook group I think I
think the thing that you have to think
about is the following it's the biggest
mistake that so many young entrepreneurs
are making right now everyone's like I'm
starting a lifestyle brand and I know I
know you're not saying that but you are
kind of saying that let me explain what
I mean by that cool you starting a
community around conversation what you
have to first realize is if you're gonna
start a community and it's just about
the organic community means you're not
gonna make any money the first couple
years yeah so the first thing you have
to decide is how you're gonna live and
whether that's living at home and not
having any expenses or having another
job and doing it from 6:00 to 2:00 in
the morning
both are cool yeah but you have to make
remember the switch you have to start
understanding right now that if you're
gonna do this right
you're actually not gonna sell anything
for a couple of years so so you're you
know you're in one big mode of creating
community I think a facebook closed
group is a great idea I think building
an email list is smart I think building
out a text message list is smart I think
it's really smart to be deep into the
comments section of your social and then
extract them into first in line got it
yeah watch what I do not what I say
right but the biggest thing you first
have to understand and the biggest
[ __ ] thing that people struggle with
at 22 to 28 is being patient is building
towards something real you have to
realize how awesome it is to not have to
ask anybody for money for three years
cuz everybody else is asking for
people's money and I don't feel like I
need to ask for money like I've never
felt like I'm good funding good um so
then I would be honest with you I don't
think you need that now I can tell you I
don't think you need your business
partner you need to build a community
okay
you don't need an Operations or business
person yet you're not doing business
that's true
got it so what you need to do is pour
your heart and soul into conversations I
would highly recommend showcasing other
people in the community so I if I were
you would do a Facebook live every week
with one of the commenters from the
community because that will get other
people in the community to comment more
which will make the community better
because we're trying to win the golden
ticket to be on the Facebook live okay
super I'm going yeah thank you
yeah um those would be I would just
build that's how I would do it okay
cuz I've actually I want to funnel a lot
of my personal following into that group
because I'm kind of the same
so I would throw right hooks on
Instagram stories okay
swipe up join the group it's a good way
to not it's a good way to throw right
hooks without throwing too many right
hooks stories I think are more you know
kind of like there's so much it's kind
of like Twitter you should add something
to your email signature with a link to
it it's a very lightweight way to do it
every time you're emailing somebody they
might see it I have my social media
profiles I guess put your bleep in there
join the community I like that thank you
the other thing I had an idea on was I
started this thing I have a personal
website just connected to my Instagram
and I called it people I know because I
think people always want a
recommendation from someone things whoa
so throughout the last year connected
with a ton of people through the
Instagram from vaynernation and do
people still pop up because the contents
on the internet yeah
oh it's I mean I was flooded at first I
think I got eight thousand like within
24 hours dollars um and it's
progressively just grown to now it's 26
I think but it I try to do all my deems
but it still just as 99
you must at all times I know and they're
all commenting back from the video base
to get razzed to a lot of people like
you [ __ ] like like I was so really so
awesome I would have thought at least
twenty percent would be like wake the
[ __ ] up you know just by the nature but
not yeah and in the comment section
everyone attacked back like I never
commented back to them I'm like I'm not
gonna do not short yeah um but my
followers started to comment back
basically doing it for me and then I
just died so there's like zero negative
it's me happy yeah and then the other
cool thing is they're all damning me
basically saying thank you and I'm like
other than there anything yeah by Gary
but so that well it takes two to tango
right it's yeah it's just a moment in
time it is it's just a moment in time
here's the best part the this is what's
great about documenting this whole
journey for me like this is so
interesting you know like in so many
ways you have to take the momentum of
that call and apply it now what you need
to do now let me let me like all these
cute answers questions you have here let
me give you the only answer that matters
okay I'm being dead serious with you
every minute you have for them now you
don't have the same experience aim life
and you're over communicating your
truths a lot of people hold them in
that's how you can win the most then it
was a great day so Gary tomorrow's a bad
day today that all that document thing
not creating right but the other biggest
thing you need to do is showcase them
within you this can't be just if you're
gonna build a community can't be just
about you it was easy for me to be about
me because I'm coming from an expertise
not just a documenting place yeah I put
in the 20 years of work and skills to be
able to be the talker when you're the
documenter of something like this I
think it's more powerful for you to
bring them into it okay I'm telling you
Facebook live it's going to like like
kind of just like how was your week kind
of segment like with that person I did
something
at one point I made a post I remember
but I was like I want to choose five
people and just zoom with you I got a
zoom call and that was really cool
Facebook live because the Facebook group
is your big thing okay I like that
and I'm started using facebook Messenger
as much as possible to the know you
human Facebook you have to understand I
asked you the most important question
where which is where is this gonna live
your answer with space bucket yeah so
live and messenger need to create that
whole you know kind of stratosphere make
sense
you think building a community through
Facebook is still the police to do it I
think bass books is an incredible place
to do it I do and even though your
community probably will skew young and
not overtly spending time on Facebook
everybody still kind of has it or could
have it and Facebook's group's
infrastructure is a very good
infrastructure for this kind of [ __ ] Oh
matter of fact it's one of things that I
want to do more of okay cuz that was the
one thing that I wasn't I got it sure
you need a home and I think the group
can help you I like Facebook groups cool
cuz I hate but listen to me are you
doing anything do you have a job yeah I
work for my mom she's I remember family
business great so that's even better
like make sure you deliver for that but
like every [ __ ] minute okay look this
is something I think people forgot I was
running Wine Library and building Wine
Library TV I used to run the business
until 7:30 drive back home to New York
and from 8:30 to 2:00 in the morning I
just answered all my email all my
comments on my wordpress from y9b TV and
went on Twitter and searched blind
conversations and engaged I used to go
to sleep at 2:30 to 3:30 after I'd
already made it to build what I've built
for four years every day okay it works
it works but it's you know it's like a
brain [ __ ] like I'm telling you it's
you've got to do it completely all in
five six hours a day seven hours a day
after you work on the family business
until like midnight one o'clock two
o'clock and this is just based on your
ambition like by the way you can do
whatever you want you can hang out every
day but like if you want it to happen
okay well if you want to do it
that's what you have to do and you have
to do it for three years and ask for
nothing because at the end of three
years when you ask for people to buy one
t-shirt
you'll sell more t-shirt after giving
three years of love in one day then you
would have been all three years if you
sold them every [ __ ] day yeah and
I've stopped I don't believe in the buy
my shirt type of crap so I kind of cut
all that and because you saw but you
didn't have the leverage yeah you had my
teacher that's right
you had my fan base trying to build a
community with you off of this magic
moment of course they weren't gonna buy
it it was fun I caught it wind have been
at one point maybe like you know three
or four months after like somehow and I
saw something
and I was like watching it and I almost
themed you and I was like I'm gonna let
her go through this herself and I'm
gonna see what she does with it okay I'm
glad that you got to this place now you
know it for yourself now it's time you
spend the next [ __ ] three four years
of your life building equity then you
can figure out what to do with that
equity yeah because I'm trying to figure
out what that and that's what's so great
about I did too it took me years of
engaging before I was like okay Wow
do you think I knew when you're you're
when you were yourself when you are you
you don't know what makes you special
what's that you don't have context I
mean all the things that people admire
me for they just seem normal patients
don't I don't even know patients was a
thing it's just what I did I didn't know
work ethic was like I didn't know any of
these things were a thing I didn't
realize I was emotionally intelligent I
didn't realize I loved empathy and
gratitude it took me time which is
totally what I went through in the last
couple years I went to some Tony Robbins
events and stuffs like figuring out who
I am like yeah but but look you went to
those events and yet we still had the
call and you were [ __ ] nowhere right
what are you talking about what Bishop
got it got it got it got it got it
perfect maybe six months I got it it's
about actions whether you [ __ ] get a
call with me or go to an event [ __ ]
it's about actions so net but you've got
to get that trigger yeah you're on the
path yeah honestly that post where I say
like close your eyes until you're 29
that's basically the advice I'm giving
you right now just [ __ ] close like
you know what to do now just [ __ ]
give but the one thing
is the truth there's only two things I
think you can give you built this little
base off of this moment awareness to the
rest of the community members of each
other by doing these Friday live streams
or however you decide my one do one
every night yeah and your cutes of the
ups and downs along the way those are
the only two things you documenting and
and being a platform for others is the
leverage for now it's all you've got the
gift okay now what do you think of
documenting just like webcam style
straight on it don't think just
documenting the whole day sure cuz I did
I mean document the whole day's ties I
tried it and I was like I can you can
you snap along the way like stories you
know like don't overthink that okay
alright I got a bounce I don't know it
also ask you anyway good cuz I've given
you the [ __ ] answer
no it's just closure it's hard it's hard
I know you know what to do it's hard
it's like close your eyes for four years
nothing good is gonna happen for four
years if you do the [ __ ] right things
for four years I don't know it's just
been this crazy year of complete
self-awareness doubling down on my
strengths and not focusing on the stuff
that I'm not great at so I tried really
hard to want to do you know the whole
Facebook ads thing and I tried to do it
for my mom's company I didn't know what
I was doing it wasn't really something I
was passionate about was Facebook ads so
don't do the things that you're
passionate about and the one thing that
I really really did which I totally
totally recommend is do more try new
things get new hobbies do some sports
start painting like literally the more
you try the more you'll know if you like
it or not which tells you more about
yourself which tells you maybe if you
want to completely change industries I
went to school for fashion and design so
I started a fashion apparel business and
found that designing is kind of not what
I want to do I don't want to sew clothes
I don't want to you know do the fabric
thing
I love the creativity behind it I love
the designing I love picking you know
the colors and drawing and all that
stuff and only through doing the stuff
did I figure out what part of it I liked
do more it's pretty simple